this morning on the dish chef hilary
sterling of chi siamo the italian phrase
roughly translates to we've finally
arrived and is meant to make guests feel
at home but it aptly speaks to the rise
of sterling from the blue collar outer
boroughs of new york to the top of big
apple cuisine
chi siamo the new italian inspired
eatery helmed by chef hillary sterling
is one of new york's hottest places to
dine
look at that
aided by the hearth in the heart of its
kitchen there's something about building
it and like producing that yeah
and that's just a special moment do you
see how it like dances
and the flavor that it imparts
you can't get by just turning on a
burner to put that to the test we
prepared a wood-fired whole trout
stuffed with pine nuts and mustard
greens this for me is a complete dish
you have your salad you have your
protein that's all we need to do it took
just five minutes on an open flame you
ever burn yourself um
yeah i mean this is just hot it is hot
if you can't stand the heat
get out of the kitchen
that's your fish oh yeah not bad for a
girl from sheepshead bay brooklyn way
past the shadows of the manhattan
skyline describe your upbringing
i grew up in the same house my father
grew up in and my grandparents lived
with us it was kosher in the basement
and not kosher upstairs
my parents
loved food we definitely ate a lot of um
they'll kill me for saying this as
always take out a lot of chinese food
and uh but we ate together every night
maybe watch jeopardy or seinfeld
sterling began busting tables at 14. i
wanted to work and the closest place to
work to my house was a restaurant slowly
working her way up the ranks eventually
landing at bobby flay's mesa grill
last april after numerous stints in
kitchens around the city sterling got a
call from famed restaurateur danny meyer
asking her to join his union square
hospitality group you're one of the only
people that danny meyer has literally
picked from outside his
his
family shall we say i mean he
he's an amazing man and an incredible
leader and why wouldn't you want to team
up with someone like that that's him
for you
what was it about you for him um we
share a common love of italian all
things italian a passion that began two
decades ago i was traveling for about
six months and i started off my trip
with a friend
and
you know long story short friend ran out
of money three weeks in so i kept going
and i went to florence and i went to
rome and i went south and i kept coming
back to rome over and over again
and i just fell in love with it those
trips what she saw how she felt helped
her create the menu for chicciamo this
is one of my ultimate favorites the
pizza bianca i ate something similar in
a small town in piamonte would you like
to give me a piece as you describe this
so
um
this and then these anchovies are from
spain
and then there's a chili underneath not
spicy
called the cenisei pepper and there's
just so much in there that in in one
little bite and brings you it
it wakes up your mouth
and brings you to the small town with me
the sun is shining we're drinking a
beautiful ball of wine and having a
beautiful just bite of toast there's the
caramelized onion torta with balsamic
and pecorino toscana and so for me the
insulin de mari
we are on the amalfi coast along with
rigatonia alegria and taglitel with
buffalo butter and tomatoes you're not
having any i'm having the lemon torta
any day anytime barely enough room for
the bomb bologna with chocolate amaro
and then we dip right yep
chicamo which opened in october was
forced to shut its doors for a week
during the busy christmas holiday season
but it's back open hopefully for good i
don't know where we are in this pandemic
but we're still in it i'm wondering if
there was some anxiety around
that not knowing where we're headed yeah
we i mean i
listen you open a restaurant in pandemic
no pandemic
you still don't know where you're going
we all know what has happened before we
know the story we just don't want to
rewrite it and we don't want to do it
again so
you know we got to keep doing what we're
doing keep helping people get vaccinated
keep pushing the team to get their
boosters and fingers crossed you know we
can make it through the winter
because we will have a very large patio
next summer that'll be ready
and i'm ready to go can we go to the
patio summer patio sounds really nice
we've got to get this going well i
brought in goodies i love her by the way
she's she's awesome but the goodie of
the negroni right and the goody of the
lemon torta with the lemon olive oil and
you know this is all the creation of
claudia fleming who's our pastry chef
right and we've had her on and what are
you used to that i'm gonna try oh yeah
sure it's here
cheers cheers cheers to 2022. there it
is i guess we already did it once a week
but this is
what we get away with hold on see the
model works there it is take a little
just a teeny teeny taste oh that's
delicious a teeny taste i'm going to
take a huge